and I need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician Bella abuk is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or Bill
Clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer in my
desk
[Laughter]
gety what's happening sorry
El you got bored in the middle of it
okay I L I
got oh [__] that's funny okay okay
sometimes when I
wipe I'll wipe and I'll wipe and I'll
wipe and I'll wipe 100 times still poop
still poop let me check that it's like
I'm wiping a marker or
something John
Rio
John
rapio what
say what's your name again Elise yton
elain
sarin
sorry Elise
sarkin do that
again sorry stupid oh my God
no hey Jennifer look what we can
do
she's not even she
Jennifer Jennifer jennif look Jennifer
look what we're look what we're doing oh
really Jennifer he's actually in me
Jennifer
Jennifer I got it I got it nice oh yeah
I also got some dude's
briefcase believe believed in you buddy
but you should put that back yeah how
did you get
this well
what that is [__] hilarious you
shattered you shattered it not only you
hit the shattered it that's not
something that props can fix that's
going to be a little harder to fix some
sorry I'm
out man I'm in love with you because
you're just like me you're a dog date me
and I'm
single Ron you're going to construct the
stage yes ma'am I really think we should
try and involve this talking
dog an will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog I've ever
seen he remember when we had sex in the
gutter on Rodney Street I'll never
forget it D I'm going to come over there
and [__] you
up Leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about
sex no one wants to hear that why don't
you tell us about your escap pigs you
little minks what the [__] is wrong with
you Mr dwire were you aware of funds for
tennis court the Miss note requested
that was denied by Mr Ron Swanson that
was later approved by Ben Wyatt no do
you play
tennis I don't know are you aware of
what tennis is yeah what point comes
after
juuce
wipe I'm going to go to the bathroom and
powder my nose amongst other things if
you know what I
mean dude is she going to powder her
vagina oh I'm sorry dude is she G to
powder
[Laughter]
her I you can we just get it on the next
s yeah okay okay
okay a vanilla chai latte for my young
Nubian
Princess step
one we buy into this club step two we
roll over to the club either in your
Mercedes-Benz which is gorgeous or my
pre-owned Acura Legend which is all
right step three I dagger you on the
Dance Floor Just Bounce Bounce Bounce
bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce now
everybody's watching
us I'm so sorry step three I dagger you
on that dance floor and dress you with
my eyes until at last it's just me and
you naked on the Dance
Floor you going to throw up you're going
to
smile okay well we just have to work
harder I mean good news is we can a
night and get a super early start on our
door to door
tomorrow he's like are they going to let
me go with
that okay well we just have to work hard
oh
no well we just have to work harder I
mean good
news first truck a Lo and it's
gone I'm sorry I'm so sorry it's a
problem now and I'm
not I'm not happy about this Factory
explosion and nobody
died
sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry you guys I'm sorry this is totally
unprofessional let's just keep going and
we'll come back to it come back to
it
no
hey we put in the car no you forgot
sorry wait I thought I put it in park
and does this help this helps a
lot it's hard right mhm things are going
to
[Laughter]
get
God
it's like being left alone in a room
with two cameras and no
people things are going to get better
right banana man that's it's
[Laughter]
close where are we
going to your mother's
butt ah I think you make a right turn on
uh wait a minute my mother's but
so uh maybe we should just write um
things down go from there will you do it
because I don't know how to write print
or aiz get the [__] out of the T If
You're gonna laugh who my name is
Annabelle Vander crank from the Memphis
Vander cranks and I just about lose my
head when the sun falls down on
my my mustache is coming up okay I'm
sorry I need my mustache
glued listen it was very cool of you to
ask me to come here I'm
uh I'm excited yeah we are too so let's
get this threeway
going and go
ahead cross yep yeah [__] my pants on
camera check everyone loves a good
comeback story right Sea Biscuit the
Mighty Ducks Robert D Jr who else Rocky
yes Kim Kardashian Kim well well in the
video she gets she gets come on her back
I
[Laughter]
think
bye
Carl I don't mean this in any bad way
but have you ever made out with another
woman
why cuz for my analysis I think you'd
love
it